myself and others became the wrong kinds
of gay because I think that sex actually
matters I think that sex is immutable
that doesn't mean to say that I'm
transphobic or something it means to say
that I think that trans people have an
extraordinary story to tell but it's a
different story to tell a trans woman
has a different story to tell than a
Than a Woman and you know that's just to
me the richness and that's why I wrote a
book called The Power of difference
rather than the power of sameness
so my difficulty with Stonewall is that
it isn't building those broad alliances
that it needs to do it's trying to force
through
a set of legislative Alternatives which
frankly don't have for the support of
the broad public whereas actually what
we drove through did have the support of
the broad public